[Music]
hey
why is it so early what are you doing
in your time zone get back i mean
it's night here i don't know what you
want me to do oh my god
so usually ken is the one having to wake
up early when you were living
back in where did you live america
mississippi in
in the river yeah just in the river the
girl mississippi that's where i live i
come out there with my catfish
and my frogs and my guns why do i not
know where the [ __ ] you lived
wait are you looking it up right now no
i don't remember
tell me it was mississippi yeah america
it was mississippi yeah you said it yeah
oh i thought it was like a joke no
there's the river and there's also a
state called
the forgotten state called mississippi
that i lived in
well i forgot it so that's true anyway
today we're looking today we're looking
at
meet the woman addicted to eating her
husband's ashes finally
what she eats her husband ashes how many
calories and
man i don't know i mean he's pretty
cooked so
looks looks like quite a few like so
she's a cannibal
hell yeah does that count it
if it's cooked or not there's a lot to
break down
before you even watch a second of this
video oh man
oh it's it's overcooked oh that's fine
then you know
it's fun it's like we go to a barbecue
and someone's like well how do you want
your steak and they're like you know
done and you typical americans
[Music]
oh of course if they went to your
barbecue they'd ask for some fish
because
yeah yeah put some barbie on the shrimp
mate
no they don't even say that yeah they do
no
that was a marketing thing in america
like they call them pogs
they don't call them shrimp on the
barbie the barbie is the barbecue right
you know the
grill put some put some brownie on a
barney
okay wait it's a lie it's a fabricated
line yeah it's a lie
it's marketing man just to sell how what
was it
was it from who was it outback we're
making it so it's the outback steakhouse
it's a mississippi conspiracy here right
watch this video all right i gotta see
this woman need her husband
sorry we always go on tangents and we
never get through the video
26 years old i'm from fifth well
she's 26 kim let's just say she has not
found the elixir of life
she's gotten she's got no secret home
remedies happening for her let's just
put it that way
which husband you think she's on right
now
i'm from fayetteville tennessee and i'm
addicted to carrying around my husband's
urn
wait just carries it that's a that's
okay at least
yes less weird at least you know
it's just one of those things where like
you want to admit something embarrassing
and then you just admit half of it and
people are like oh that's not that weird
but in reality you do all these
[ __ ] yeah anyway
i take my husband everywhere oh hell
yeah
to the grocery store shopping sorry that
was a bit insensitive it's just kind of
weird
that's so weird someone says wait sorry
i always look in the background for
stuff this is this thing over her
shoulder what is that it looks blurry to
me
is that like oh my god creepy is that a
it's like i can't tell if the video is
is glitching or if that's real what is
that
she said in a weird antique shop and she
decided to bring her dead husband
yeah he's going to haunt something and
then someone's going to take it home and
there's going to be
terrible accidents that happen that's
why she's going to usually no usually
you find haunted items at these places
but no she brought one
she's trying to get rid of change like
can we take this
[Laughter]
i can't tell if this is incentive like
someone's dead
and it's just weird but okay we we
make we're here we're not here to be
like
not me no that's true
you know that's me what are you doing
with that to the movies
out to eat anywhere i'll go he goes
to eat huh she put the seat belt on him
god just kind of left him in the bed
oh wait did she put the seat i didn't
notice that anywhere i'll go he goes
strap him up no
i wouldn't be so harsh on this unless i
seen the title you know
right exactly and i i know where this is
going
i don't know if it's too soon to be like
you know like wonder if he died in a car
accident and she's
like you know
that's a good joke well done
[Laughter]
i can't you should get like a not a
pillow that wouldn't make sense but
maybe like like a rubber ball or
something a rubber band
like a rubber doll like with those real
dolls and like sprinkles
that will definitely get haunted yeah
god that'd be
scary just thinking about it that's kind
of cool
why you don't want to become a doll ken
all right no dude yes
all my plants are cancelled but
now she's just got to go it's too early
to make these jokes
[Laughter]
when i cook i cook what he likes i don't
eat it
but i cook for him she doesn't eat it if
i'm watching tv
she doesn't eat it oh crap what did you
throw it away
yeah yeah yeah we know you're not
throwing it away all right girl
if somebody says hey who is that i'm
like this is my husband some people
laugh they think i'm playing
but i mean it's serious it's my husband
hmm see no game it is serious and that's
why we've been taking this
very serious and and not made any jokes
so far because that would be horrible
we deserve to be canceled if we
in 2009 after dating for 10 months
everything i had ever wanted in a man
was right in front of me
and it felt so great they fell in love
and
was soul mates from day one the two and
a half years
that they were together i think was the
only time casey was truly truly happy
their marriage was picture perfect until
shawn suffered a severe asthma attack
two months ago it's only been two months
it is too soon to make jokes we are
cancelled ken
dang it you know she said that like he
was everything i ever wanted a man and
that would be real sweet
if i didn't read the title is everything
i ever wanted
man i'm gonna lick her flicking her
fingers i'm delicious
you know in a way no no
no we need to keep watching and the look
on his face
felix what's the point what what point
do we gotta get to do we can like really
just like open up here like
maybe you have to like actually start
eating this dude before it's first to be
like
yep all right all right you wait
uh a lot of these strange addictions is
that they eat
powdery stuff like chalky stuff
and that's a condition that i think it
seems like a lot of women suffer from
and it's like a lack of the certain
mineral but this makes no [ __ ] sense
or maybe there are minerals in ashes
well there's got to be something there
right i mean it's i don't know like how
do we
what google search do we put into what
is in ashes
there's just some questions not even the
internet can tell you
i guess was the day
the day my world stopped turning
today my life fell apart
[Music]
though casey initially found comfort by
having her husband's ashes at her side
her addiction has recently evolved let's
go
okay there we go of his cremains
you know some got into the cardboard box
as well and they spilled out on my hands
stop stop
i love this they always have it like an
accident like
one day it just fell into my
mouth the hair was delicious
there was there's a there's a strange
addiction of a girl that eats sand and
her story was she
fell down you got a mouthful of sand
delicious
it's like they're like it could happen
to anyone
you're at the playground one day just
i'm trying to play it out in my head
right now she's get she gets the ashes
on her head
hands and it pulls like that lord of the
ring angled for like the hands down
below her she's like looking down and
she's like
after all why shouldn't i
[Laughter]
what do you what oh i got some husband
on my hand better
lick that off this did not happen
she dipped her fingers then she even did
one of those
before you gotta make like make it pop
you know that should happen i mean i do
it with g fuel i can't understand
it's delicious it's the same thing right
is this
no no it's not it's absolutely nothing
that's my husband i don't want to wipe
him away um
so what did you do yes don't try and
logic your way out of this all right
well
i'm not gonna wipe him away i'm gonna
brush him back off into the
into the box that would be so
disrespectful
obviously the most courteous way to
handle this situation
is what i call a little suck no you know
what all right
is she eating it there is she doing it
off my face
just keep watching let's see here i am
today
almost two months later and i can't stop
this is not real it's not real
i don't know i mean i hope not because
this is we're
we're watching a cannibal in action
right now he's just he's just extra
crispy and she's just going to town
i'm eating my husband
oh oh my gosh she's really going for
how much of him is left she is chowing
down on this man right now
yeah yeah if there's only been two
months i mean
girl that ain't a that's a limited
supply you got there
well she's gonna have to get married
again and have an important house
she looks so sad when she does it dude
felix what better way
to honor your husband's memory than to
eat them
and then poop them out and flush them
down the toilet yeah
that is a way better thing than just
wiping it off
absolutely if might say ever
you know i'm not getting cremated after
i sing this oh she's gonna
eat you it's a not an impossibility
clearly
oh my god dude you get to become like
the creepiest little
animal figurines in the world though if
she like sprinkled you on like the furby
or whatever
with oh that's a good idea
yeah for me in those dolls oh hell yeah
isn't it isn't it like i don't know if
it's true or not but like if if you're
like a cat lady and you die in your
house your cats
and you can't feed your cats some of the
cats eat you i don't know why i just
call it that
she's going to feed you the pug now pugs
don't will not they will
they they won't do that ken they won't
eat me i would never do that right
no and that's why dogs are better than
cats because cats actually eat
yeah is that in the room right now with
you yeah he's looking at me
look look at him in the face tell me he
wouldn't need you
[Music]
oh i thought he was grabbing you i got
both the plug is here today
watch out you're dating me numbered i
mean maya will definitely eat me but
edgar no they're so tired and like what
the [ __ ] are you doing to it
we will eat you after you did this you
were woken up
anyway first i like my finger
oh she does dip it in i swirl around to
kind of feel
and get it caked on there good
and then i just eat it that is
offensive revolting
yeah i'm just i'm just blown away i'm
just oh my god
well he sounded like he was a very bossy
husband to begin with because he's been
dead but she watches what tv show he
wants to watch
she makes some dinner and everything
maybe this is just revenge like i'm
gonna show you she looks like she's
digging pretty deep in that bag too
i mean she said it she said she doesn't
just dip
she's like i go way in there you think
she's self-aware too like she's gonna
talk about like
one of my concerns is that i'm running
out of them you know
i gotta get more husband oh every time
they uh
they have these they go to a doctor
right and the doctor is like
the doctor's gonna lock her up
but the doctor is always like this is
really hey guess what eating mattress
that that might
kill you you should probably say yeah
and they always go like
what no
oh but we'll i don't know if this will
kill you
well sometimes they talk to a doctor and
sometimes they talk to like a family
member about it right or both
oh that's going to be a family member
yeah
this is probably the most offensive
video i've ever watched
sand insanity she is but i've grown to
love that taste
it started as she said it tasted like
sand yeah like sandpaper and
it's bad yeah she's grown delicious so
she wasn't like
delicious she was just like
it's like drinking beer you know like
the first one you ever have tastes like
butthole but then you just keep making
yourself drink it you're like oh i like
it now
stockholm syndrome right is that what it
is don't don't don't put the sweets on
this
here pika have you heard of this it's
when people are
addicted to eating like dirt clay and
stuff
and it's a condition because it can be
caused from pregnancy
mild nourishment in iron
yeah mary has to take iron supplements
with her with her oh my god ken
i'm looking behind me man
i'm a thick boy so i got plenty of it if
an accident never co
happens to you ken i'll go to australia
i don't know if i can joke about this
i'll go to miami like where you see what
have you done
wouldn't be done with them hit it with
those knife tape
i'll take care of him all right give me
the ashes and then i'll sprinkle them
on mars if you eat me
i'll mix him with gpu
his views are mine i will continue
i will become stronger i'll get a
charming
southern accent all of a sudden oh yeah
then you'll be able to say
eating him anyway lost 42 pounds
since my husband passed away damn she's
lost weight
sure come on with that cookbook
eating your husband
i want to lose 20 pounds
the miraculous the revolutionary new
method
it'd be a new fad diet just eat someone
that's been cremated you'll lose so much
weight
all right this is fun
the only thing i'm eating are his ashes
casey that's all she's eating husband's
exclusive diet dude how long this cannot
last much longer
i almost want to congratulate her on her
willpower because i can't even stay on a
regular diet for like
two weeks she's eating nothing but ashes
it is commendable i will give her that
absolutely
five to six times a day
when i open up the urn i get a sense of
happiness
it's like yeah she looks ecstatic
exciting like the face is making she's
like looks at that face every time she
pops open he's up there judging like
wow yeah wow really big
is that what you do to me why
we were married two months come on
god an adrenaline rush for me and
the more i eat the more excited i get
until i realize
there's not a lot left then yeah a few
minutes later
i feel horrible because i did it ah
get out of here you don't get a sip of
that
this is me when i had like really
expensive whiskey and you know it's
running out and you
i had the exact same [ __ ] the reaction
yeah no why doesn't it last forever
oh my god did you ever see the lady that
uh
gets bees to stinger on purpose so and
then the bee stings her and dies and
then she cries about it
oh she i miss that she cries about it
yeah she's like oh
it's dead then she gets another one to
sting herself she like plays like
songs for him oh it's what
yeah is there another one because uh the
one i saw didn't do that
really oh no yeah it's a real short part
of the video but yeah yeah she's all
i'm just i'm just going to the cycle of
like these addictions they have they
like do it and then they feel ashamed
but then like you know
next day right back at it again this is
me binging
i'm like i'm so fat but man
it's too real but not you can relate to
this is that
when i got shawn back from the crematory
he weighed six years he is closer to
five pounds now so i have
consumed all right all right so she's
good for another uh
one pound per month so another year
going on four months ready go ahead and
express on the uh
on the list some other things no no
no i it's early okay shut up
[ __ ] it i wasn't sure how much she said
in
her my head yet all right okay all right
god damn it don't do that
edit it out for the love of god you're
sick of this [ __ ]
every other editor editor people say
all right it makes the video better no
it doesn't
cause i suffer oh let the memes flow
no he is closer to five pounds now so i
have
consumed right out of pound
wait a minute she said she's two pounds
she has five pounds
left she's two two pounds
it's sorry one pound in two months that
means
she has 10 months left i thought they
said she ate more than that earlier
but i don't know the numbers are all
over the place
you didn't correct me ken huh huh
it's early in the morning man you know
you're having a rough time
the fact that it took me three tries to
get that right oh yeah
very few people know that casey is
eating her husband's ashes
well we all know now don't we
everybody knows that secret is out
that's almost the same thing with these
like i
would i would never feel comfortable
telling anyone about this
just sit for the camera thank you but
tsc paid me fifty dollars
so i guess she recently shared this
secret with her mother
thank you oh we got to see that nice
yeah
she would never dare tell anyone unless
the camera crew was here but they're
like we need some
more to fill out your episodes go tell
your mom or something yeah
how did tlc find her i i feel like this
isn't
i hope this isn't real she actually told
me that she was
eating shawn's ashes it was like i
couldn't speak
i really couldn't do anything i mean
it's like i was just frozen there
it makes me feel embarrassed
ashamed disgusted with myself confused
crazy
it's a big one that pops into my head
gotta be really sick person to eat
someone's ashes
that is interesting how she realizes
that
she's fully aware i guess that's what
makes it an addiction
i mean i guess you don't have to be
aware but still that's interesting
yeah i don't know it's weird to me that
she didn't even like it at first but she
just did it and now she likes the taste
now it's an addiction
was she not self-aware then girl you
need help someone give her help please
but i mean this is also a problem that
will solve itself
in 10 in 10 months right we'll just let
it run its course and you don't have to
worry about anything but
i'm still worried if we need to lock her
away for being a cannibal or not
this is cannibalism she's admitted to
meeting her husband
several times in this video and what
form he is in i don't know if it really
matters
but i guess it does because she made the
video and they didn't call the cops
owner
that's true maybe she's in jail now yeah
that's got to be illegal
it's got to be right it's got to be
illegal if not
i'm probably going to be eating their
husbands yes
oh they're breaking down the the science
behind it
it's coming i waited for this oh fine
eight different
chemicals can cause psychosis
she's been tripping out this whole time
that's why she keeps eating it
oh my god she's like dang this husband
is
hitting hard they were like
maybe we shouldn't put all these
chemicals in what if someone
accidentally
eats it no like no one would actually
who would do that right
throw them in there yeah but what if
someone drops it on their hand
and they want to be respectful instead
of just wiping it off that would be
bad what else are they gonna do if that
happens
i mean shoot next time you know like go
the toilet i'm using that cheap toilet
paper and my my finger slips through the
toilet paper and you know i get a little
accident
everybody's disrespectful to yourself
right that's normal right that's
probably what she's gonna do
when she when she runs at a husband
that's what she's gonna do she's gonna
realize
that the husband's in the poop and she's
gonna start pooping the box and eating
it again
oh god that it's the circle of life man
it's gonna happen
some some images i don't want in my head
and now you've put them there
it's panicking me and it's uh worrying
me
that she's losing three out even more
and i need to do what i need to help her
get past that
take him from that a pound is already
gone take it from her
anybody i need help she's got 10 months
left take it
tell someone in his family don't tell
your mom tell someone
oh i want to see that god i want to see
you sexy mama
be like you better step back
what am i gonna do when i go to bed at
night and there's just an urn there
and there's nothing in it but can casey
quit her addiction to eating her
husband's
she's ashes hammering down on it i just
want her to stop
eating the ashes that's my one and only
hope for my daughter
stop it i have to stop it i've lost
just stop it this time it'll be my fault
that i lose them again
this i you can't make this [ __ ] up ken
honestly
i wonder how much of her husband she ate
with the production crew here being like
okay well we need to see you eat the
ashes so let's get a couple of shots ah
you know that was good but we need to
redo that again can you hit it again
from this angle
she's probably at home she i'm sure she
doesn't mind [ __ ] these 10 months i
think she's going to speed run it
speed her on oh god and it's going to
get to that point where
oh that was like a little bit oh
get help get help someone just take it
to reveal the truth to her cousins
usually they they're quite empathetic
these therapists that they meet them up
with but i want someone to just come and
slap her
and take her if if she told this man's
mom
then she would be slapping she's gonna
tell her cousin who
yeah right oh [ __ ] weirdo i always
knew you were weird
i'm feeling anxious a little bit um on
the gazebo
let's go to the gazebo i'm ready to tell
that's the right place they always go to
like a public place
i have something to tell you stephanie i
don't know i don't want to freak out
and i don't want you to get mad and i
really don't want you to push me away
and not talk to me anymore
she has the right to do all of those
things
just because you said that doesn't
change anything all right
i've been eating his ashes
that's it that's it wow
wow
that's crazy wow that's
wow well she doesn't want to seem too
shocked you know she doesn't want to
like
get on the hit list she doesn't want to
get canceled she's like okay
acceptance understanding of course well
i'm just going to go back home
and never talk to you again so uh bye
oh i definitely won't push you away i
promise
he'll always be a part of me because i'm
eating him you know
yeah no don't stop with the logic on
this
that is not how that works
what part of him does she think her body
is absorbing
he's ash but i don't know what to think
about that i mean
it is a kind kind of a little too much
maybe maybe it's a little too much
maybe she threw a maybe in there uh you
know have you considered you know maybe
slightly not doing that you know
i don't want to spend you eat sand eat
some santa this one girl i saw a video
she loves it
or rocks yeah that's a great time all
right eat drywall
eat mattress all right
any of this would be better than what
you're doing do you understand
i'm pretty close to the edge right now
and if i eat him
like all of him and maybe ten months
baby
10 months you got 10 months but then
again where's my comfort going to be
what do you mean i don't want to be oh
there's a little crazy lady that ate her
husband
i think that train
definitely too late for that certain
things you do
people will just kind of remembering
somebody get this lady a hobby teach her
how to play match at the gathering or
something she needs something else to do
with her life other than eat her husband
i sh shower once people judge me for my
life all right
you better be judged for life for this
and i had an
excuse when we first started he was six
parents right now he's
almost five pounds right you know and
wait so if he's
almost five pounds let's say he's like
5.2 or something
okay that would mean another six months
not even six months six months
someone teaches dumb some math huh
idiot that's like shoot six pounds
that's like the size of a small baby
she's eating over there wow
oh god i just visualized six pounds
that's a lot to eat
yeah oh oh there it is she's a cannibal
yeah damn props to tlc crew for
uh for
i wouldn't want to be i wouldn't want to
be shooting this i'll go back down to
the uh the comments real quick
her husband and heaven be like
[Laughter]
oh maybe after she eats all the ashes
he'll finally take her body over and
he'll be reborn on this earth you know
no one's tried it so far you never know
well ken that was a trip that i don't
ever want to go through again but it was
enjoyable and entertaining
and nonetheless it was entertaining and
i don't feel bad about any of the jokes
we made
no i don't i don't cancel me i don't
care
okay someone cancelled her she's eating
her freaking husband jesus right exactly
anyway if you enjoyed this video smash
like subscribe check out ken's channel
the tfc videos together and i'll see you
next time
my face please don't eat me
let's see it's kind of a power move
isn't it
eating someone's a power move yeah and
for you that cam i'm [ __ ] eating
well if you die i would eat you but
you're nothing but freaking skin and
bones i'd starve to death
yeah well maybe then you lose some
weight [ __ ]
probably hey
if you die i'll eat you and i'll [ __ ]
you in the shower [ __ ]
oh that's a shower how could you don't
have to spray me down
oh you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use
any item in your inventory and make
memes inside tuber simulator
add some of our patented stickers in
there stickers are emotions
memes are emotions express your emotions
with me
share them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows maybe i'll review your
memes the greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this